well three major Aid groups have
suspended their operations in
Afghanistan saying they can't work
without their female staff this follows
an order by the country's Taliban rulers
telling all humanitarian organizations
to stop employing women the ban comes
just days after the group barred women
from attending universities
Taliban are trying to erase them from
public life but Afghan women are
fighting back not letting the Taliban
Crush their dreams
in this alley women protesting for the
right to University education were
dispersed with water cannon
we are not carrying any weapons the
Taliban forced us to come to the street
and then they used water cannons on us
we all got drenched and many girls fell
down they are scared of our voices and
don't have any other weapons we want our
rights
The taliban's Assault on women's rights
shows no sign of stopping
women humanitarian workers are
desperately needed in poverty-stricken
Afghanistan now they're being told to
stay home
the U.N has warned against limiting
women's role in the humanitarian sector
effective human Insurance assistance
relies on the meaningful participation
of women as they stated and we cannot
overstate the importance of their
capacities insight and ability to reach
women and girls across the country
despite worldwide condemnation the
Taliban are not going down to the
pressure and their closing dose to any
meaningful engagement
for more I'm very pleased to welcome
Aramis alakbarov Deputy special
representative of the UN assistance
mission in Afghanistan he also
coordinates 28 ngos in Afghanistan so we
have three major ngos announcing they
are going to be suspending their work in
Afghanistan after the taliban's ban on
women's staff do you believe that that
is the right response
well there is never a good choice when
we're talking about the suspension
Afghanistan is the poorest country in
the world one of the poorest for sure it
has an extremely high level of people in
need but it's also true that the
participation of women staff in the
discharge of humanitarian work is an
essential
um principle of humanitarian to Aid
delivery and we cannot deliver Aid in
unprincipled way
okay I want to ask what kind of
communication channels the UN has with
the Taliban what kind of pressure might
you be able to exert that would change
their minds on this issue
I wouldn't use the word pressure I
wouldn't say the world negotiations uh
the fact of authority of Afghanistan and
as such the duty bearers they bear the
responsibility the prime responsibility
for provision of Aid to the people of
Afghanistan and we are here in our
impartial capacity to deliver that age
to the people now if we cannot deliver
the aid we have support required and
facilitation required and that includes
having women uh participating in
Assessments in discharge of the service
and in provision of Aid this is
essential elements of operational
Independence not applicable just
Afghanistan this is a universal
principle of delivery of a humanitarian
Aid so what we are talking to them about
is that we need to make sure that they
provide us with the required conditions
so that we can assist the needy people
and that's where our conversation ends
up so without those conditions can you
tell me a bit more about how this ban is
going to affect the un's work in
Afghanistan
uh first of all uh the ngos around
implementing part so you cannot extend
the certain bands or restrictions and
ngos and expect that um will not be
affected so uh as such this is not an
NGO issue it's an entire issue for us as
the International Community and as they
that's number one uh the effects are are
very simple if we're not able to assess
the communities if we are not able to
deliver Aid there then the people will
not be benefiting from it and it's a
cold winter and we need to make sure
that food blankets
um cooking materials and everything else
what makes essential life-saving
assistance available is reaching
communities without any disruptions
that's why we're talking to the de facto
of where it is we are engaging them very
proactively and we're asking for the
reversal of this uh
okay I want to thank you so much for
joining us on DW news to speak about
this important topic that's around
Deputy special representative of the UN
assistance mission in Afghanistan